[Music]
there's no shortage of ladies flaunting
their figures on instagrams but make no
mistake there's plenty of guys bearing
it all - he's so dreamy asleep take
Justin Bieber he put his buns on full
display during a tropical getaway
[Music]
then there's John Legend his wife
Chrissy Teigan loves all his curves and
edges so much so she posted this
bootylicious snap when he wasn't looking
Wendy Wow come here while Darren Criss I
see you the actor recently gave fans
some full-frontal actions thank you for
sharing this with me is pretty
incredible Cody Simpson took in the
ocean view
so did Bachelorette stars chase McNary
and Robbie Hayes I dare you to strip
down their booty is looking toward as
ever
Pretty Little Liars star Tyler Blackburn
opted for a little skinny-dipping in the
pool I'm excited to represent for it you
know and then there's Taye Diggs let me
show you how happy I am who may not have
even known he was blessing us with his
booty when it showed up in the mirror
while taking a selfie did I do that
lots of beautiful behinds which one is
your favorite tweet me and let me know
[Music]
you